CBS News senior national security
contributor Michael Morell was deputy
director and acting director of the CIA
Michael good morning good morning
Anthony what was that drone doing
exactly and and was it as the Iranians
say an effective provocation so that
drone was doing what drones do all over
the world which is surveillance so that
drones job was to watch the Iranian Navy
particularly smaller Ronnie and navy
boats to make sure that they were not
loading weapons that they were going to
take out into the Persian Gulf and
conduct attacks that was the purpose of
the drone Charlie what I mean
Michael was it in fact in international
airspace is there any possibility of
that I mean in Iranian airspace excuse
me it's designed to fly in international
airspace is it possible that it drifted
off course and went into your Ronnie in
airspace
yes the Pentagon says that's not the
case I think over the next couple days
you're gonna see both sides trying to
prove what they say so what options do
you think Michael that the Trump
administration has now to sort of
de-escalate this situation seems to be
getting very dicey
yeah Gail this is I think the key
question this is another step up the
escalatory ladder as are all the other
attacks that charlie pointed out
particularly attack in Saudi Arabia
against the desalinization plant that's
critical infrastructure for the Saudis
so there's been a series of attacks here
what we need to do is we need to make
clear to the to the Iranians that they
cannot get away with this but we need to
make sure that we have our allies on
board in whatever we decide to do what
the Iranians are trying to do is divide
us from our allies so what makes sense
to us is bring our allies together and
let's let's take action that stops the
Iranians from doing this but let's do it
as a coalition all right Michael Morell
for us in Washington Michael thank you
very much